we're going to talk about four paradoxes
that touch on the topic of infinity
first one we've got the Hilbert Hotel
this is a hotel with infinitely many
rooms and at the moment there's somebody
in every single room so it's a full
hotel and then a new customer rolls up
at the reception desk now you might
think they got to turn them away because
the hotel's full but the managers clever
and here's what he does he shifts the
person in room 1 to room 2 and the
person in room 2 to room 3 and the
person in room 3 to room 4 and so on
everyone gets shifted forward one room
because there's even plenty many rooms
you never run out of rooms to put people
in and when you've done all of this room
one's free so the new guests get put in
puts in room number one so you can fit
in a new guest
you could fit in two new guests you
could fit in ten new guests and even if
an infinite bus of new customers rolls
up you can fit them all in I guess it's
that when I first heard the description
I thought that hotels full you can't for
anybody in it
that's how full hotels work but then
once you're shown that you can fit as
many new people in the hotel as you like
you learn something new about infinity
so your intuitions change and the trick
is because it's an infinite hotel there
is no final room if there were a final
room you could count all the rooms and
they wouldn't be infinitely many of them
I think he's using the idea to say you
know infinite is interesting it's
philosophically interesting because you
might have thought things went like this
but they don't and we can show
mathematically that they don't powerdocs
number two this is the paradox of
Gabriel's trumpet so the idea is we have
this mathematical shape this
mathematical object it's shaped like a
trumpet it'll start off here and it'll
taper and get thinner and thinner and
thinner and thinner and thinner and it
tends off to infinity getting thinner
and thinner all the way so that
mathematical object has an infinite
surface area but the volume it encloses
the air in the center of the trumpet is
only a finite volume suppose you were
told you had to paint
the inside of that trumpet well on the
one hand you've got a pain an infinitely
big surface so you're going to need an
infinite bucket of paint but on the
other hand you could just take a finite
big enough can of pain tip it into the
trumpet and let it filter its way down
so it looks like you only need a finite
amount of pain to paint an infinite
surface area that's really really
strange if we're thinking about real
physical pain you just can't paint the
whole surface because it gets so thin at
one end but you're just not going to fit
the paint down there so I guess the
clash arises when we think about the
difference between the mathematical idea
of a surface and the physical idea of
paint which is real thick stuff if we
had mathematical paint where the
molecules had no size whatsoever looks
like you need an infinite amount of that
to cover that infinite surface area he
thought there was something really
strange going on here he gave lots of
proofs with this idea because I think at
first he thought he'd made a mistake a
lots of mathematicians thought that
there was something wrong with the idea
of infinity that maybe somehow we should
banish infinity because puzzles like
this clash they show there something
wrong with the idea so we should somehow
ban it from our mathematics but in fact
infinity works just fine in mathematics
but we have to sometimes change your
ideas about how the world works to fit
it in number three so this is the puzzle
of the dartboard
so we suppose we've got a dartboard and
we've got a dart and we're going to
throw the dart at the dartboard and
let's just suppose we're guaranteed 100
percent chance to hit the dartboard and
then we ask the question think about the
exact center point of the dart and we
think about an exact point a
mathematical point on the dart board and
we ask the question what's the chance
our dart is going to hit that exact
point and it turns out we can't give a
sensible answer so suppose on the one
hand that we say it's got a chance
greater than zero of hitting that point
well there's a problem with that if it's
got a greater than zero chance of
hitting that point the same goes for
every other point on the dart board
and there's infinitely many of them in
fact there's a big infinity of those
mathematical points when we add all
those chances together to give us the
chance that the darts going to hit the
dartboard at all we end up with an
infinite probability we can't have an
infinite probability you can't get a
probability bigger than one that
something will happen okay so we've got
a problem with the idea that the chance
of the dart hitting that point is bigger
than zero so on the other hand what
happens is the chance is zero but that's
also strange because if the chance of
hitting that point is zero we could say
the same for every point so the chance
of hitting any point on the dart board
is zero it's not going to happen but
that's really strange because we're sure
the darts going to hit the Darr board
somewhere again one thing philosophers
say about this is the idea of banning
infinity so we say don't think about the
exact mathematical point of the dart we
think about an area any real physical
dart has an area at its center and we
think about what's the chance that it
hits an area on the dart board and then
we divide these up in a finite way and
the problem goes away as the area gets
bigger the probability that the dart
hits there is bigger as it gets smaller
the probability of the dart hits there
gets smaller so it's this kind of
granular nature of our existence that
gets us out of trouble yeah that's right
so if everything that we think about is
an area rather than an exact point the
problem goes away
but that's not completely satisfying
after all we can think of an area
getting smaller and smaller and smaller
and tending to infinity shouldn't we
have a decent answer to this problem
when we get to the infinite case and you
know maybe we don't have a very good
answer to it okay so here's the fourth
paradox this is perhaps the most
interesting one of them all because it
relates to what rational humans should
do in betting games you go to a casino
and they put a pound in the pot and they
say we're going to flip a fair coin and
when it lands on the tail you get
whatever's in the pot if we flip a head
the casino doubles what's in the pot and
we play again
if it gets a tail you get what's in the
pot if it's a head they double the pot
and we carry on playing and then they
ask you the question how much would you
pay to get into this game name your
price
you've got to pay something to play what
would you pay I think most people think
about this a bit and say something like
maybe a few pounds maybe if you're rich
you'd say 20 pounds the mathematical
theory on the other hand tells you bet
whatever you've got stake any amount of
money you can get your hands on on this
game because the expected winnings is
infinite you're expected take-home is
infinite if you play the game - the way
we work out the expected take home
winnings is we look at each case if you
flip a tail on the first go how much
would you win add it - if you flip a
tail on the second go how much would you
win added - if you flip a tail on the
third gear how much would you win or we
sum all of these but because the game
hasn't got a fixed end point we sum
infinitely many of these and in fact
what you would the expected value of
each player of the game is 1/2 so we're
adding 1/2 to 1/2 to 1/2 to 1/2
infinitely many times that's why the
expected value of what you'll take home
is infinitely big but we wouldn't bear
absolutely we wouldn't get everything I
wouldn't I don't think you would and
what does that say I think it says
something interesting about perhaps
about us
perhaps it says that we're more risk
averse than the mathematical theory
would have us believe
perhaps it says that the value of money
changes the more you accrue perhaps it
says something else that we haven't
quite worked yet that we should figure
into what makes us rational reason is
that we haven't yet taken account of in
the maths you're sort of saying that as
if humans are wrong to not bet
everything on it but surely if humans
did their casinos had set that game up
and own all their houses by now well a
good point to make the maths come out
the casino has to guarantee so you have
to know in advance that they will bet
as much as they need so they would have
to be a casino with an infinite amount
of money potentially to put into this
game so one way out of it is to say look
there's no casino with that amount of
money and if we say after X amount of
money's been put in the pot that's it
that's all the casino can do then the
numbers change and it turns out you'd be
irrational to put lots of money into it
we have this mathematical theory of
rational decision making and the most
mathematical theories don't crumble when
you put infinity in they work just fine
so why is it that theories about us how
we should or shouldn't behave go really
weird when you put infinity in
so suppose we take all the natural
numbers together none of those are
infinitely big each one is a finite
number
but there's infinitely many of them so
if we were asked to count them we'd say
there's an infinite connection